BRE PETTIS: Thank you.
So I was here almost
exactly five years ago.
It might have actually
been May, 2009.
I tried to look on my calendar.
I couldn't find it.
It was so far back.
And I was introduced
by this guy,
and he said,
replicators start here.
And that was before we
even called the MakerBot
a replicator.
And so I thought, OK.
Like, I watched
this this morning.
I was like, this is kind of
like a really neat full circle
moment, because five years ago
we were three guys, a laser
cutter, and a dream.
And we'd gotten ourselves
into-- we really thought
five years ago that we would
start a business that we could
do in like 10 or 12 hours
a week on this side.
And we probably
had two employees.
So there were probably
five of us at that point.
And now we're 500-- merged
with the public company.
And this is what a 3D printed
bunny looked like on a MakerBot
at that moment.
And we were so proud.
We were like, this kind
of looks like a bunny.
This is great!
And now we have 100
micron layer resolution,
and it's kind of
absurd that it works.
And a MakerBot replicator will
go head-to-head with a $300,000
mainframe-size machine
and kick it's butt.
And any company that does
product design probably
has a MakerBot.
Car companies, phone
companies, basically
anybody who's making
stuff uses MakerBot.
And it basically takes
the way you used to do it
and smushes it up.
So the way people use
to do product design is
they used to have an idea,
and then make a design,
and then send it out.
And it would take three weeks
or a month to do an iteration.
You'd get it back and
be like, the ears are
too long, or this
needs more cowbell,
or whatever you wanted to say.
And then you'd do it again.
And with a three or four
week turnaround time,
you could iterate
multiple times a year.
When engineers get a MakerBot
and they put on their desk,
they iterate
multiple times a day.
So it means, one,
because it's affordable,
and because two, the material's
affordable, and three,
we've made it easy to use-- good
UX/UI, which nobody-- probably
this is the best room that
understands how important UX/UI
is.
Anyhow, it basically makes it so
that people can try things out.
They can explore.
They can make something.
And they don't even
have to show their boss
if they don't like it.
They can just be like,
oh, this was a bad idea.
Chuck it under the
desk in the bin.
Do it again.
It's not a problem to try again.
And that's probably been
one of the coolest things
to see as we've grown the
company is watching all
of the awesome MakerBot
operators in the world
take the technology and do way
cooler stuff than we could ever
have imagined.
So when we talk
about MakerBot, we
talk about being an
innovation company.
I talked a lot about what
companies do with it.
The cool thing is
it's affordable enough
that when we started it was
seriously early, early, early,
adopters-- Google bought
two of the first batch.
Thank you for supporting
us back in the day
--and now it's
ordinary people who
just need more brackets
for their kitchen
will get a MakerBot.
All of it has to
do is innovation.
And we like to say we're
an innovation company.
We innovate so that
everybody else can innovate.
And back in the day if you
wanted to make something,
this is an injection
molding machine
it's probably a 210 ton press.
And pellets go in one
side, and there's basically
two big pieces of metal
that are a mold that goes
[CRUSHING NOISE], with that
kind of noise and cranks
out plastic stuff all day long.
About 40 or 50 MakerBots
will compete with that, just
for fun.
But now you can have--
the way it used to be is
it was just a lot
of infrastructure.
You had to be a tycoon to own
that kind of infrastructure
to make things.
Now you just need a freaking
laptop and a MakerBot,
and game is on.
So when we talk about leaving
the next Industrial Revolution.
The First Industrial
Revolution was really
around the factory--
moving from everybody
working on stuff in their
home to everybody going
to the factory,
centralized manufacturing.
And it allowed everybody
to have things like spoons.
Well I'm sure people
had spoons beforehand.
But you could produce
lots of spoons
at one time in a factory,
or garment making
and all that kind of stuff.
The Second Industrial
Revolution is officially
classified as being around the
railroad and transportation.
So when I talk about the
Third Industrial Revolution,
I like to talk about all
these tools basically
being on your desktop--
the tools of manufacturing.
A MakerBot is a
manufacturing education
in a box on your desktop.
And we've been doing
it for five years.
And so we built out
this 3D ecosystem.
It's interesting.
We actually started
Thingaverse-- thingaverse.com
is our website where people
share digital designs
--and we started Thingaverse
before we started MakerBot,
actually.
And I'll talk about
that more later.
But we've got all this
stuff around the 3D printer,
and in some ways
getting a 3D printer is
sort of your ticket into this
whole world that we've created.
And it's just way more
than just a 3D printer.
But the 3D printers are cool.
These are our fifth
generation machines.
You know, something about
having a black background
and black machines,
I think I just
didn't do it justice
on this slide.
Important thing you
will need to know
is that there's a small
version, a medium version,
and a ginormous version.
The MakerBot
Replicator Mini makes
things that are about four
by four by five inches.
So stuff you might
want to have at home,
or you could make for your kids.
We're exploring the frontier
of consumer 3D printing, where
ordinary people just make
stuff instead of buying stuff.
This is our sort of adventure.
And the MakerBot Replicator
Mini is really our step
into the adventure
of making something
for people who aren't
engineers-- one-touch 3D
Printing.
The MakerBot Replicator,
which I've got up here,
is fifth generation
technology too.
It's basically optimized
for the engineer,
the industrial designer,
the architects of the world.
And the MakerBot Replicator
Z18 is ginormous.
Norman build volume is 12 by
12 by 18 inches, so full-sized.
If you need a full-size replica
of your head, we're on it.
What's interesting is anybody
who has had a 3D printer
or used 3D printing
before wants this one.
All the orders for
this are people
who already have 3D printers.
It's interesting.
It shops in May, or
officially in spring,
so I can be flexible if
I need to push to June,
but it should be May.
And it's going to be super
interesting to see what people
do when they have a
big-scale 3D printer.
And to get one of these-- it's
like the best volume to price
ratio.
If you want to geek out
on how awesome it is,
it just blows everything
else out of the water.
The cool thing is is that
even though we just came out
three new 3D printers, it's
kind of like we just came out
with one 3D printer, but
in three different sizes.
They all have an onboard camera.
This means that you can
pull it up on your phone
and watch your model being made
from another part of your house
or the world, or if you're in
a space station, then fine.
They all have this
smart extruder,
which just swaps in and out,
so if you need to replace it,
and it's got a
little brain in it,
so it knows when you
run out of filament
and sends a message
saying, I'm hungry.
And they're all app
and cloud enabled.
I'm sorry this is an iPhone,
not an Android device.
The mobile platform launches
in about a month and a half,
and Android will
follow shortly after.
The MakerBot replicator and
the MakerBot replicator Z18
both have this
super-luscious LCD display.
And there's nothing like going
from-- the MakerBot Replicator
2, which is our fourth
generation machine,
has a little alpha
alphanumeric display.
And I've got to say, it's like
we're moving from flip phone
technology to
smartphone technology.
It's that big of a leap.
I'm like, yes.
More than whatever it is.
More than 100 characters,
awesome, pictures, yes!
So the small one is, like
I said, for beginners.
It's got all the same things
that all of them have.
It doesn't have the display,
but you basically use your phone
as the control mechanism for it.
And the MakerBot
Replicator-- kind
of getting redundant
here --huge build volume
for engineers, industrial
designers, architects.
And then this giant one's
just out of control.
This is a heated build
chamber to reduce curling.
If you've done 3D printing,
you've battled curling.
I can't say it makes it go away,
because it's something that
happens when you use a
thermoplastic where you heat it
up and you extrude it.
The way it works, if
you haven't seen one,
is it basically draws
a picture in plastic
and then draws another
picture on top of that,
and layer by layer
it makes your model.
When you do really
big things-- all
thermoplastics shrink
when they cool.
And if they curl--
while it's being made,
it kind of curls
up at the edges,
so we've done a lot to reduce
that with this machine,
in particular.
Because with big things
it's more important,
because if it shrinks
0.2% it doesn't really
matter if it's just like
three centimeters long.
But if it's 25 centimeters
long, you've got a problem.
So we make these in Brooklyn.
Can we give it up
for New York City?
So this actually is
really important.
We did a lot of research
into making them
in all sorts of places.
And it came down
that for us it was
most important that
the manufacturing
engineers, the design engineers,
could argue in the same place.
And so we've got a facility
in Sunset Park, where
we've got a really ginormous
factory where we just
crank these out all
day long and ship them.
And it's interesting.
I think when you do
a hardware startup
you have to love
packing and shipping.
If you don't love packing and
shipping, go into software.
Well, you have to
ship in software too,
but it doesn't involve-- well,
I guess it does sometimes
involve physical stuff,
but it's different.
We love to pack and ship.
And it's funny--
when we started,
when I was here
five years ago, I
did everything with my partners.
We did everything.
We laser cut the parts out.
We call the suppliers
and grumped at them
if they were late.
We packed all the boxes,
put the stickers on them,
loaded up the UPS
trucks, and now I
have a whole team that
just loads UPS trucks.
It's awesome.
It's one of the great
things about growing
is you're like, OK I don't
have to do it all anymore.
We get to have teams
of people do stuff.
So this is on our assembly line.
So what you can see here is that
there's parts for the MakerBot
that come down
the assembly line.
And they come on these
sort of cafeteria trays.
And attached to
the cafeteria tray
are all these jigs and
fixtures made on a MakerBot.
There's more than
1,000 jigs and fixtures
at the MakerBot factory, which
are parts that we made on
on the MakerBot
to make MakerBots.
And this is actually
one of those things
that 3D printers, and
MakerBots in particular,
are going to get used for
that is not as high-profile,
but is deep.
Manufacturers, in general, when
they make jigs and fixtures,
generally have a
carpentry section.
And they just basically
set people up--
they set all there
stuff up, and instead
of having these
3D printed parts,
it's usually like pieces
of wood hammered together.
It's very piecemeal.
This is just so much easier
than doing anything else.
I mean the other alternative is
to take a material like Delrin
and mill it out and
make these things.
But when you start realizing
how much it costs to get time
on a milling machine, it's just
like-- if the manufacturers
hear this and watch
this Google Talk video,
and their ears get pricked
up, and they get it,
then our biggest customer may
not actually be consumers,
I'm planning on.
It may end up
being manufacturers
that use this to streamline
their manufacturing facility.
So you know that
hardware doesn't
work unless software is great.
And that's one of things that
if I'm anywhere and I say that,
you all will get this.
We've got a lot of
knockoffs, but most of them
do not understand that to
make some hardware work, you,
have to make it a great
experience for the end user.
And that is almost
entirely software.
And so I love my software teams.
And MakerBot Desktop is an
application that you download.
It sits on the desktop.
And you get to enter the
world of MakerBot through it.
You can explore Thingaverse.
You can shop in the
MakerBot digital store.
You can plan your
model on a virtual
build plate, and send
it to the MakerBot
and make it a full build plate.
Inside MakerBot
desktop application
is the MakerWare, which is
the tool for-- basically,
you take it from whatever
design tool you use.
You can use anything.
When I was here five years
ago, you owned Google SketchUp,
so I did a big thing on that.
Now you've sold that, but really
SketchUp, Pro/E, SolidWorks,
AutoDesk-- AutoDesk actually
has a great suite of stuff
if you're just getting
into it with 123D.
You can really make--
if you want it,
there's really no
excuse anymore.
It used to be you could
say, oh, I don't know CAD.
But now the tools
are easy enough
that you can get into it, even
if you've never done it before.
Easier than Photoshop, is
what I'm comfortable saying.
We've got it set up with a
cloud solution, so you drag,
and you can basically
organize all your models.
You can organize all
the things you've ever
made on your MakerBot, so
you can see what you've made.
If you want to make
it again, it's easy.
And we do 3D print monitoring
from this application, as well.
And then you can
access Thingaverse.
Let's see.
I'll come back to Thingaverse.
Thingaverse may be the
coolest thing of all of this.
Same thing with the mobile app.
You can cruise everything,
monitor everything.
And we just announced it, and
we're about to ship PrintShop.
PrintShop is a tool
that is really--
if you want to design something,
we're making a bunch of tools
so if you can type you
can make a 3D model.
So you just type
this in to PrintShop,
and it makes a
three-dimensional sign
for your desktop, or
your door, or whatever.
And then we've also
got a bracelet maker,
so if you need to make
something for your sweetheart,
it's pretty easy.
We made it easy.
That's the whole idea.
So many people-- I'm a
former school teacher,
and I taught in the arts, and
so many people go through,
particularly public school,
and come out thinking that they
can't do anything artistic,
because they didn't draw
a house the same way that the
teacher wanted them to draw it,
or they didn't do
something the way they--
they got a C+ in creativity in
school for something that they
weren't even attached to.
If we can reignite-- if MakerBot
can have any part in reigniting
even just one
person's creativity,
I feel like we'll
have been successful,
because there's just so
much that can happen when
one person gets engaged,
starts having ideas,
and starts making things happen.
So PrintShop is our answer
to get people who are just
beginning into this jump started
into the process of being
creative.
I've also hired this
exceptionally bad ass team
of designers that
just make cool stuff.
So this is-- oh, we don't
have a picture of the--
we've just got a
picture of the model.
This is actually a full-sized,
realistic samurai helmet, cuz.
And we've launched the
MakerBot digital store
to basically make it so that
anybody, even if you're not
a designer, can just go and
buy 3D models, make cool stuff,
make your family happy.
We're doing entertainment,
and the next step,
we're going to a bunch
of practical stuff.
But for right now
you can basically--
you get an immense
amount of cool models.
And we have a model
where you basically pay--
kind of like an app
store --$0.99 each,
or you could buy a
whole set for $9.99.
And then you can
then, of course, you
can paint them--
very satisfying.
So this is a little
bit-- this is
about two or three months old.
There's significantly more
MakerBots in the world
than this, because,
like I said, we're
packing and shipping
like mad right now.
And then-- oh good.
Now I'm to the part
of my-- now I'm
talking about Thingaverse again.
So Thingaverse is
what happens when
you take an engaged community
who make digital designs,
and you give them a
place to share things.
We started Thingaverse.
And Thingaverse is still
place where-- It's actually
interesting
archive.org just crawl
the site and
archived everything.
And it's something like more
than 100 gigs of just models.
So I think if you wanted to
make everything on Thingaverse
with one MakerBot, it
would probably take you
a couple hundred, if not a
couple thousand, lifetimes.
So it's just make
the stuff you want.
So this is just so cool.
One of my favorite
things to do every day
is I go to Thingaverse.com,
our website,
and I'm just like a power-fan.
I like to look at everything
and see what's new in the world
that you can make
today on a MakerBot
that you couldn't
make yesterday.
And, to be clear, we're
actually agnostic.
If you have a different
kind of 3D printer,
you can use the same
files, so do it.
There's a bunch of
stuff we're doing
to optimize it to make it
really easy for MakerBot users,
but whatever you've
got come and share.
And if you make cool
stuff share it here
if you're comfortable with that.
It's a lot more than this
now, but there's just
a lot of digital designs.
And just a lot-- our AWS
bill is kind of absurd.
This is a project, This
is the Robohand project.
This is every once in awhile
I got journalists asking me,
so you just make
tchotchkes right?
And I would have to
resist the impulse
to hit them in the face.
And then I'd tell
them about Robohand.
So Robohand is a project.
It's a collaboration.
Two guys collaborated
to develop the hand
that you see on this
screen here for this kid.
And it's a prosthetic hand
that really anybody can use,
but it's optimized for kids.
Kids who are born with
amniotic band syndrome
don't have fingers.
They have a palm,
but no fingers.
And they don't get prosthetics,
because they grow out
of them like sneakers, and
they cost like $50,000.
So Robohand is like
$5 in material.
And it will take you a
couple hours to print out.
And it's basically great for
picking up balls, picking up
things, holding a pen.
There's a young
gentleman who went--
he has amniotic band syndrome
--he went to his school.
His name's Leon.
He used his school's MakerBot
to print out a Robohand.
And we were interviewed in the
same place, and he was asked,
so are you going to change it?
And he's like, yeah.
I'm adding lasers.
So this kind of
transforms kids' lives.
Now they get to go to school,
and they're like Iron Man.
That's Leon there.
He's caught a touchdown
with this thing.
This is John Camp.
This guy is hardcore.
He's at Lockheed Martin.
He's working on the James Webb
Space Telescope Project, which
is so cool if
you're a space nerd.
And they realized that
they had a problem.
They had the Space Telescope
in the cryo chamber--
I just like to say the
word "cryo chamber" --which
is super-cold, as close as
you can get to Kelvin chamber
with all the air
sucked out of it.
And the idea is
to simulate space.
And it stays there for like six
months, or something like this.
They realized while it
was in the cryo chamber
that there was a problem
that they had to fix.
And there was a chance
that with the tolerance
deck up cosmic rays could
get into the telescope
and ruin the sensor.
They went ahead, and
they made a model.
The white stuff
that he's holding
is a model of the
part of the telescope
that they were going
to have to modify.
And the green parts in
the photo are the parts
that they were going to
have to insert-- baffles.
Now, the tricky
part is it's a way
deep down in the depths
of it, and they're
going to have to send a
little snake camera down there
and use a bunch of tools.
So they printed out a
replica of the telescope.
Printed out all
the parts that they
we're going to have
to update it with.
Printed out replicas of the
tools they were going to use.
And they practiced
for a few months.
And when it came out of
the crowd chamber-- bam
--I guess it was like
a 20 minute procedure.
So he reckons it probably
saved them six months,
because they were
able to do it while it
was in the crowd chamber.
And there's no official
amount that they saved,
but it was probably millions
of dollars on the project.
So cool.
And it's interesting, he
brought in MakerBots to do this.
And he's in a cubicle
a Lockheed Martin.
And people are immediately
like, what's that sound?
Why do you get a MakerBot?
And so they sort of started
proliferating through.
And actually at JPL--
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
--when they have to
prototype something that's
within the build
volume of a MakerBot,
they don't send it out first.
They just buy a MakerBot
for that engineer,
because it's cheaper than buying
one prototype in one part.
And it also is less
than the minimum
needed for
bureaucratic oversight
on the credit card, so protip.
Uncharted Play-- these
folks are in Poughkeepsie,
and they are awesome.
They are making tools
for the developing
worlds that basically are cool.
This is one of their things.
Do I have the-- no.
They also make a jump rope,
that when you jump rope,
it's got a USB socket
on the jump rope.
And 15 minutes of jumping rope
will charge your phone totally.
That seems not a lot
until you've actually
tried jumping rope
for 15 minutes.
But this is a ball
that has a gyro in it.
When you kick it around all day
it stores energy in a battery,
and then you can do
your homework at night.
You can't really see
this photo very well,
but-- oh, it's a
shame --right next
to her are two
inserts for shoes.
And they're like
the kind of things
you would get if your
feet were messed up,
and you went the doctor.
What are those called?
AUDIENCE: Orthotics.
BRE PETTIS: Orthotics, yes.
Right next to her
are two orthotics.
She's super-happy
because she just
got back from the
amusement park.
She's 41 1/2 inches tall.
Those orthotics don't
do anything for her feet
except make her
half an inch taller.
So she could right
all the rides.
So basically this
is a MakerBot dad
who's like-- MakerBot
operators live for this moment.
Oh, you're not tall enough?
I got that.
Kacie Hultgren in New York City.
She is a set designer pioneering
3D-printed set design.
She's got shows on Broadway.
And she's a pioneer
in set design.
But then having a
bunch of MakerBots
stacked up in her closet
running 3D prints overnight.
And the goes in and
argues with the director
about what the set
should look like.
She's also a pioneer--
all the stuff she makes,
because it's all period
furniture models.
She has a whole
other business she
started at prettysmallthings.com
selling dollhouse furniture.
So whatever your passion
is, add a MakerBot
it and a little
entrepreneurialism,
and game is on.
So cool.
She shares these models
on Thingaverse too.
So if you have a MakerBot,
just download them,
and when you're shrunk
you'll have good furniture.
Bitonti did a project working
with students at Pratt.
He's a legit, totally
superstar fashion designer,
and he's making dresses.
We actually have one hanging
up at our store right
now on Mulberry Street,
just north of Houston.
Its hot.
Local Motors is
an awesome company
that makes desert
rally race cars.
And they realized that the
the mirrors were not far out
enough on their rally fighter.
So on every really
fighter they actually
print out little
extenders for the mirrors.
see a lot of MakerBots
in classrooms.
And this is Ryan Cain.
He actually has
students make houses,
prints them out, and he has
a whole large diorama set up
that everybody puts their
houses right next a river.
And then they take a hose and
run a hose through the river.
And the kids learn about erosion
by watching our house float
away.
We're on a mission , actually,
to put a MakerBot in every
school in the United
States of America.
We started, and we're
actually working
on our second stage of
basically looking for funders.
We basically give
an amazing deal
to funders who support a
teacher in getting MakerBot.
We partnered with
donorschoose.org
There's actually
stuff there now,
if you want to go up
and see if there's
a school in your neighborhood,
or your school you went to,
that wants a MakerBot.
And it's at the teacher's pull,
and then they get support.
And a lot of times
they don't even
need to wait for a
funder to fund it.
Communities are using it kind of
like a Kickstarter for teachers
to just get this
technology in classrooms.
And I would equate it to
when I was a kid in 1981 ,
there was an Apple II Plus
in my classroom that gave me
an unfair advantage over the
rest of the world as a nerd.
And we're seeing the
next generation--
there's a different kind
of nerd that shows up.
In many ways, we've taken care
of most of the computer nerds
in the world.
Young people access
like never before,
especially in this country.
there's the kids who like
to work with their hands.
And I'm not sure if you
know, maybe you're like me.
When I was a kid
I took auto shop.
I took wood shop.
I took metal shop.
And there was even home ec.
I liked home ec too.
That's all gone.
All those programs
have been decimated.
one of the cool things is,
when you put a MakerBot
in a classroom it uses
all the technology that's
available-- the computers
in the classroom.
And then allows young
people to actually do
things that are physical,
that are real in real life.
And it just activates a
section of the population that
isn't being served
by schools now.
It'll take us three
to five years to do,
but I think it's actually
going to be one of the things
that I think will basically
be our legacy if we do it, is
getting this equipment, getting
this technology in schools.
So if there's the right
person in the room,
or you can point me
to the right person,
I would love to connect and
amplify that with you all.
And so you can just go to
MakerBot.com/academy to learn
more.
that's the end of my talk.
I've got a bunch of stuff
here that I can show you.
And then I'd love
to take questions.
I'm expecting good questions
from this audience.
So I've got a jet engine.
This is one of the
designs that-- Chunky
Trucks --that you can buy.
It's really awesome.
And it's all one print, and
it prints without supports.
Two-color, geometric thing.
This is a Voronoi Vase.
You know what, actually?
There may be some
community models here.
I think this one might
be a community model.
I'm going to have
to attribute this,
and in the comments
of this video
I'll make sure everybody
gets attribution.
That's important to me.
A really nice bud vase, I
showed you the Robohand.
This is cool.
This is printed in one print,
but it prints everything
just with enough tolerances
away from each other
that when you snap it off it
turns into like a necklace.
Easter was big on Thingaverse,
oh man-- that little bunny.
You got one of
these little things
that's like a distraction tool.
This is a big version of that.
It's the exact same
model, just scaled up.
For the MakerBot Academy stuff,
we're creating curriculum.
So we also created-- this is
the Great Pyramid of Giza,
but when you open it
up, you can actually
see there's a
little map in here,
where you can see all
the secret chambers.
We also did a 3D-printed
dissectable frog.
Saving frog's lives.
And a chip bag holder.
So let's see.
So I'll stop.
I'll say thank you and
then we'll take questions.
Thank you very much.
You know what?
Before I do that
though, can I just
ask-- I was here exactly in
this spot five years ago.
I know there's at least
two people in here
--can you raise your hands if
you were here five years ago?
One, two, three, four.
Oh, that is--
AUDIENCE: May 22.
BRE PETTIS: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's May 22.
BRE PETTIS: That's when
I was here is May 22?
AUDIENCE: 2009, yeah.
BRE PETTIS: Oh, cool.
Thank you.
OK, first question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
I have a Replicator 2 at home.
BRE PETTIS: Awesome machine.
Workhorse.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So two related questions.
First is, your new print head.
Do you-- the problem of
extrusion, sometimes.
And the problem is that
you have a long print,
and it stops in the middle.
So your new print head, which
is a very low, low detail here,
it just makes sure that
if you run out of filament
it tells you.
But there are so many
other the problems.
I cannot tell-- I have a list of
things, and it stops printing.
And it runs.
It makes noises
and does nothing.
Does your new print head
actually either stop
or actually prevents a
problem from happening?
BRE PETTIS: So one of the things
about-- so the Replicator 2
has a tool head that's
what's called "open loop."
So that means that it
doesn't have a sensor that
knows-- if it runs out of
filament, it doesn't know.
It just keeps going.
If it gets a jam.
If there's a bunch of
dust on your filament
that gets in there, clogs up
the nozzle, it doesn't know.
And it's come a
long way, actually,
from when we launched
that print head.
But the new smart extruder--
there's three sensors in there.
There's a hall effect sensor
to make leveling a lot easier,
so it knows where the
extruder is in relationship,
so you can make the build
platform very flat, which
is another challenge
with the Replicator 2.
Very doable.
It just takes a little bit
longer than you would like.
And then we've got
sensors in there
that both sense whether
the filament is there
and how fast it's
going in there.
So we're trying to
address all the things
that we wish we'd
done back in the day,
so there's a lot
we've addressed there.
Have we addressed everything?
I'd love to say yes,
but I think we're
going to find as we're shipping
these that there's probably
something that we'll need
to do for the next one.
The cool thing with
the smart extruder
though is it just pops off,
and it's held on by magnets.
So if and when we ever do do
an upgrade to the extruder,
you can just by an extruder
rather than a whole new 3D
printer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Follow-up question-- if
you have Replicator 2
and you want to upgrade
to a new technology,
the problem is you have to
buy new stuff from scratch.
Do you have any
idea for trade-in?
BRE PETTIS: You know, I've
got an Android 2 phone
that we can talk about.
AUDIENCE: It's $2,000 thing.
It's not just a smartphone.
It's a $2,000 uhh-- for people--
BRE PETTIS: I'm not sure if
you were here at the beginning.
We've got Adam here.
There he is in the back.
We do have a special thing for
people who are in this room.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
BRE PETTIS: OK?
Talk to Adam in the back there.
Great.
Next up.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Have you
done much thought
about how this affects things
in the developing world context,
because it is transformative,
but the biggest problem
they have is often
just getting the PLA.
BRE PETTIS: Yeah,
and then there's
also juice-- electricity.
So there's a group,
iLab, that is super-cool.
They needed umbilical
cord clamps.
They had a MakerBot.
They just make them.
And it's actually
now the local supply
for umbilical cord clamps.
There's huge opportunity there.
And there's huge
opportunity for people
who are connected so
that they get there
and they can know
how to use it, have
the resources, and
enough material.
The good thing is actually a
roll of MakerBot PLA filament
goes a long way--
390-some-odd chess pieces
from one roll of filament.
So in theory, someday you
might be able to make your own,
but right now the machine
that makes filament
is the size of a semi truck,
so probably not this year.
But there's all sorts of
room to innovate there.
AUDIENCE: Sort of to follow on--
you explored it a little bit,
is there any hope
of getting something
to make filament
out of PET bottles?
BRE PETTIS: Funny you ask that.
One of the challenges--
so I had an idea
we first started the
company to use an apple
corer to take to bottles
and just make strips
that then you could feed in.
The downside is
that would only work
on bottles that are more
than like 30 years old.
Because since then they've
optimized the bottles,
and all the bottles are
different thicknesses
depending on how much
stress they're under.
So there is a group,
though, that-- this
is so cool --there's a group
at the University of Washington
that entered this contest or
this-- th Milk Carton Derby
on the Lake Washington.
And the idea is you have to
make a boat out of milk cartons
and race it.
And they're pretty loose on what
you do with the milk cartons
and how you do that.
So this group took a
bunch of milk cartons
which are made out of
HDPE-- thermoplastic
--and they actually had a really
hard time keeping quality,
because every different
kind of milk carton
doesn't necessarily have
the same quality plastic.
And anyway they put those
literally in a blender,
and then made an extruder that
had a really thick nozzle,
like 1/2 an inch.
And then they extruded a boat.
And when they show up they
said, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is for boats made out of
milk cartons and milk jugs.
And they were like, uh huh.
I think they probably
changed the rules next year.
But there's all sorts
of opportunities there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRE PETTIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I've got a
whole list of questions,
but I'll just ask one for now.
What are some of those short-
and long-term issues impeding
the progress of 3D
printing, and what
are you or others in your
industry doing to solve them.
BRE PETTIS: Hoo.
One of the biggest ones
we have knocked down.
We've done.
So when I was here
five years ago,
I had to explain what 3D
printing was as a concept,
because nobody understood it.
And when I talked
about 3D printing,
I might as well
been talking about
like-- I don't know
--teleportation or something.
Same thing, but yeah,
I feel like we've
done a pretty good
job, because we took it
on as our primary mission first
and foremost to educate people
about the possibilities
of the technology.
And I feel like we've
done that, actually.
I think once we got on the cover
of "Wired," we're like, OK.
I think most people have
at least heard of it.
Now I think our big challenge
is how do we get people
to the point where they
think it's not just
for early adopters.
That it's normal to
use a 3D printer.
So I think that's our
biggest challenge,
is how to educate the public
to just be like, yeah,
I just whipped it
up on my MakerBot.
No big deal.
I want that to be normal.
Right now there's 44,000 or
more people with MakerBots.
That's like they're already
living in that future.
And I think sometime this
year, we'll get to the point
where more than 50%
of the population
knows someone with a 3D printer.
How many people here know
somebody with a 3D printer?
OK, for this room we may
have already gotten there.
But that's, I think,
the next big hurdle.
And that's more of
a social engineering
hurdle than a technical hurdle.
AUDIENCE: Could you expand
on technological problems
you might be facing, not just
cultural adaptation ones?
BRE PETTIS: I think the question
you're asking is sort of like,
can you tell me all the secret
stuff you're working on?
And the weird thing
is, though, just--
I hate to give you a
social engineering answer.
The other thing, on
the technical side,
it's actually making it easy.
I don't know how many of you
are early adopters, who've
bought stuff on Kickstarter, and
you get it and it doesn't work.
But making things
to work easily--
and this is where I lean on
my software department really
heavy --is the hardest
thing so good UI, good UX.
We take a lot of pride in it.
We're working really hard on it.
And that to us, we
believe, is the key
to unlocking MakerBots
for everyone everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRE PETTIS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BRE PETTIS: Oh, I'm
going to come over here,
and I'll come back to you.
We'll go back and forth.
AUDIENCE: I'd read recently that
the core patents around laser
centering have just expired.
I wondered if you guys were
going to have any plans?
BRE PETTIS: I heard that too.
So laser centering,
just for everybody,
is where you take a bed
of powder and a big laser,
and you laser the powder,
and it fuses one layer of it.
And then you make a
very fine layer of power
over on top of that layer,
and you fuse it again,
and it fuses to the
layer underneath.
And this is super cool.
At MakerBot we're focused
on-- where did you go?
Oh, there you are.
At MakerBot we're
focused on-- I'm
like what --we're
focused on making stuff
that you can have
in your living room,
on your desktop, that
can be truly universal.
And with the laser
centering stuff,
that powder's so fine that you
have to wear basically a gas
mask when you're around it.
I don't foresee a
family wearing gas masks
to do something creative
going to happen anytime soon.
So for us it's not
really-- I can't
say we'll never do it,
because I never say never,
but it's not our
primary focus right now.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So, thank you for
coming, and my question
is are you exploring any new,
different types of filaments?
BRE PETTIS: Maybe.
We have a couple.
So we have a MakerBot
PLA, which is--
PLA stands for polylactic acid.
It's a renewable bioplastic
derived from corn,
so it smells good
when you make things
with it, which is--
you'd be surprised
how important that is, actually.
Like our the first
two 3D printers
we had were primarily
for ABS, and even
though we did the
tests, and it's not bad,
it smells like hot plastic,
which is not awesome.
Having PLA in your home is kind
of like you're making pancakes,
is what it smells like.
And it turns out that does--
I think in some ways smell may
be one of our most
important purchase factors.
That being said, we've also
got-- so we've got ABS.
We've got PLA.
We've got MakerBot flexible
filament, which is super cool.
And then we've got a
dissolvable filament.
It dissolves in limonene, which
is like a nontoxic cleaning
product.
Smells like oranges.
Again, smell.
There is a whole frontier
of different materials.
And we have some
limitations on how much heat
we can have into the
extruder, which limits it.
And it's one of those things
where it's very frustrating.
We've done a bunch of
research on a bunch
of different materials.
And we're like, OK
here's the new material.
Is it better than PLA?
No.
And I don't know,
like, material science
you're limited, frustratingly
enough, to the periodic table.
And so when we
find better things,
we'll absolutely release them.
And I wish I could
make that happen faster
and add elements to
the periodic table.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRE PETTIS: Cheers.
Back here
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So, HP announced
they would soon enter
the market of 3D printing.
So I was wondering, what are
your thoughts about these
either traditional
printing company,
or bigger consumer electronics
company coming into the market?
And what's the
impact for MakerBot.
BRE PETTIS: So we've been doing
3D printing for five years.
And Stratasys is our
we-- that merged with,
our sister company, has
been doing it for 25 years.
And Stratasys is sort of a
unified group of the smartest
people in the world
pioneering 3D printing.
And in many ways it was so
cool to get together with them,
because all of our engineers got
together with their engineers.
And we were like, we've
got these problems.
We're wondering if
you have solutions,
because you've been at for
like 20 more years than us.
And they were like, no those
are just hard problems.
We've got them too.
So I think that when you think
about competition in the world,
people entering the
market, it's-- well, one,
it's still so early,
so fricking game on.
But I'm not really
worried about it.
We're an innovation company.
We're focused on empowering
people to innovate.
Yes, over here.
AUDIENCE: So I have two things.
One is a follow up to the
filament question earlier,
and there's a separate question.
Are you familiar with Filabot?
BRE PETTIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, so your response
didn't seem to indicate that.
Sub-$600 filament creation
from plastic shards and you can
grind up previous prints from
your existing replicator.
BRE PETTIS: So, I
don't really like
to talk trash about anybody.
And it's a really cool thing.
And there needs
to be more of it.
In fact, people need
to get these, find out
that they need a lot of
work, and then do the work.
And it's a cool project, and
people will absolutely do that.
It's one of those
things though, that you
should look into what
you spend on energy.
You need to do it.
You need to spend the
amount of electricity
you pump in to make it happen.
And the whole experience,
and how fast you can make it,
and decide if that's where
you want to spend your time.
The other thing that we
obsess on pretty hardcore
is ultra-high tolerances.
And it's both
tolerances in terms
of diameter and roundness.
We have a roundness tolerance.
And neither of those
things are trivial.
And, again, our setup
for making filament
is the size of a semi truck.
So we're not doing that just
because we like big things.
It's because we're
really obsessed
with making exceptionally high
quality filament that will just
work and maintain
high tolerances.
So exciting possibilities
are out there.
I think it's exciting.
I think that so many people
get excited about recycling
filament.
I think it's just
not a one liner.
It's not a one line solution.
AUDIENCE: All right,
separate question
is, replicators
cost a lot of money.
How much work are you
putting into trying
to get affordable
printers out to people?
You talk about trying to target
schools and things like that,
but it's difficult to get
these into people's homes
if people don't have
$2,000 to spend.
BRE PETTIS: How much
was your laptop?
AUDIENCE: My current laptop
or my previous previous?
BRE PETTIS: Let's
say previous laptop.
AUDIENCE: Around $500.
BRE PETTIS: OK.
Well, I guess you could get a
Chromebook for like $1 now too.
So I'm not going
to win on that one.
We took a product that was
$100,000 and we made it $2,000.
So 50 times reduction in price.
It turns out that to get lower
than that-- it's possible,
but there's a few things
you have to do to do that.
One, you can go the
Raspberry Pi way, which
is the way most
Kickstarter products go,
where they don't realize how
much build materials are.
And Raspberry Pi
is a great computer
you can buy that costs $35.
And it's at cost.
And the company that
makes the chip on it
wants you to use Raspberry
Pis, because then you're
going to prototype another
Raspberry Pi and by that chip.
And Raspberry Pis
are super-awesome.
They're empowering people to do
wonderfully stupid things that
are super innovative, that
move the world forward.
But they have a
motivation to do that.
So if you don't mind
not making any money
or building a
sustainable business,
you can build a RepRap,
which is actually,
if you want to get into
low cost 3D printing,
and you don't mind spending
a couple hundred hours--
AUDIENCE: I have a Prusa.
It's kind of broken at the
moment, but I have one.
BRE PETTIS: Right,
see-- that's the trick.
And Prusa actually,
to its credit,
built a platform where
you can make your own 3D
printer-- a lot of them
were made on a MakerBot,
but you pay a price in
fussiness basically,
and there's no support to call.
So it depends on where
the value is for you.
I mean at some point
we may get to a point
where the hardware
is a commodity.
To make that work,
as a business,
we have to figure out
other ways to make money
to make that work.
So I can keep hiring people.
So is that a good
enough answer for you?
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Good enough.
BRE PETTIS: I would love to have
a more affordable 3D-- I mean,
I believe we are
affordable compared
to the way it used to be.
And I know we have to keep
making it more affordable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRE PETTIS: Cheers.
AUDIENCE: Hey, two questions.
First, cool talk.
Second, I have like a
300 square foot studio.
I don't have any room to put one
of these even if I wanted one--
AUDIENCE: Move to Brookylyn.
AUDIENCE: --and I kind of do.
Is there any idea
around 3D print shops,
like we have 2D print shops.
BRE PETTIS: So if you come in
with a USB stick or whatever
to our Mulberry store, we'll
just make something for you.
I mean, we'll charge
you for it, but it's
cheaper than a
MakerBot Replicator.
AUDIENCE: That works.
BRE PETTIS: So
that's accessible.
You could also go
to the workshop.
AUDIENCE: And the other thing.
Is there any-- I don't
have a good intuition
for how strong these are.
How do you learn that?
Just making stuff that breaks?
BRE PETTIS: Yeah, break it.
You'll have to get a MakerBot
and build another one.
But really, I mean, it's
surprisingly strong.
We built a chain.
And we hung from it
and tried to break it,
and we couldn't break it.
It has some torsion challenge.
If you torsion it, like if
you were to take a chain,
and you were to
go like this, you
would use less energy than if
you pulled on it to break it.
And the good thing is basically
all the industrial designers
are like, oh I'm not sure
if that's strong enough.
And then they test it,
and it's strong enough.
So I can say basically
it's strong enough.
But if you actually want
to know how strong it is,
yeah you'll have to break it.
And go for it, please.
I encourage-- that's how
we all have to learn.
I mean, I don't
have more for you.
So you can't break it
and get another one,
but please, yeah, explore it.
Try it out.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I actually have a Cupcake 3D
printer, and I really liked it.
Now the thing
you're talking about
with having the social
or consumer level
in the home, where it's just
something that you would have.
I still haven't seen the--
what I could potential
make in the future
that would justify
the cost of even a $500 thing.
I've made little
things, like I've
made a holder for
the [INAUDIBLE]
for my mom or something,
or something like a hook
to hold headphones, and
other things like that.
And they're really cool.
And I can justify that as I
bought the printer as a toy
to play with, but
I couldn't really
justify it as I
bought it to make
this little holder
for the [INAUDIBLE].
I bought it to make
holders for my headphones,
or something like that.
Where do we have to go to get it
so that you we can make things
like that people
will be like, OK?
BRE PETTIS: That's my
challenge, right there.
So first of all, thank you
for being one of-- there's
not many Cupcake
owners in the world.
So thanks to Google, and
thanks to you for personally
supporting us when we were
making our early 3D printers.
They were so fussy.
I'm so glad we're past that.
And Yeah so there's all sorts
of-- so thank you for that.
I think I'll throw the
question back at you.
I would say that while
I'm sure that-- there
are a lot of things
you can make.
We literally have high
schoolers who get MakerBots,
to go into business and make
back the cost of the MakerBot
replicator in like
a month and a half.
Protip-- make phone cases
with your school's logo on it.
Game on.
So there's stuff like that.
But I would say
maybe you just need
to develop a product
that everybody wants.
And then you go into
small-scale manufacturing,
and then use that as a
jumping board for going big.
Do you have kids yet?
AUDIENCE: I do not.
BRE PETTIS: So I have a daughter
is 2 1/2, and I come home,
and she basically says what
did you make me on the MakerBot
today?
I'm screwed.
Eventually I'll be
like, do your homework.
But I get to basically
be a superhero
around the house
with the MakerBot,
and that justifies
it pretty well--
basically being able to make
stuff like coathooks, fixing
the drain when it breaks,
and all that kind of stuff.
But, honestly, the
stuff I love to make
is all the weird,
artistic stuff.
I just printed out a model of
the Antikythera device made
by Cosmo Wenman,
designed by Cosmo Wenman.
And it's not a working
Antikythera device
for the other ancient
computing nerds in the room.
It's a model of what they
pull out of the ocean.
Antikythera device is
something that they pulled out
of the ocean about 2,000 years
ago that is a working computer.
I think it's just 70
different gears in it,
except for the fact that
gears weren't invented
for another 1,500
years, or used.
So either there's
a time traveler,
or somebody was really smart.
Super-cool.
Anyway, get ye to Wikipedia.
So it kind of depends on
what you're passionate about.
I think when people really
get crazy with their MakerBot,
it's when they
find their passion.
Whether it's a dollhouse
furniture, like I showed,
or starting a business,
or getting into something.
The quadcopter fanatics on
Thingaverse are out of control.
There's close to 1,000 mounts
you can connect to a GoPro
that you can print
out on your MakerBot.
So I would ask what's
your obsession,
and then go from there.
AUDIENCE: I've been
doing robotics, right.
BRE PETTIS: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: What it seems
like you're really
saying is the 3D printer would
be less like the 2D printer,
where it's something
that you'd have.
And it have the
same function of,
I need to print out the
documents so I can hand it
in at school, or whatever.
This is more as
something to inspire
you to do something
new and different
that you couldn't
have done before.
BRE PETTIS: You're hired.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRE PETTIS: Thank you.
Good.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's make
this the last question, sorry.
BRE PETTIS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So 3D
printing is cool,
because you can print whatever
you want within reason.
But two groups that might
oppose certain uses for it
are copyright holders,
like maybe Disney
doesn't want you to print
out a bunch of Mickey Mouses,
even though you could.
Or governments you
don't want people
to print out weaponry or guns.
So do you see them as
having a legitimate claim
to preventing
people from printing
whatever they want
on 3D printers,
or what's your take on
those sorts of impediments?
BRE PETTIS: I'll ask
you a couple questions,
and then I'll tell
you my answer.
First question, did you ever
have a cassette tape recorder?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRE PETTIS: OK, did you
ever have a VHS machine.
Right OK, maybe not?
A VHS machine.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRE PETTIS: OK, phew.
And then did you
ever have a CD-R?
AUDIENCE: Of course.
BRE PETTIS: Have you ever
watched anything on YouTube.?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRE PETTIS: Bam!
So just like YouTube, frankly,
we're absurdly DMCA compliant.
So it's not going to be
that different from issues
YouTube has.
And in fact we get them.
We have one company
that makes little tanks
that tabletop gamers-- it
costs less than $1 in filament
to make them on your MakerBot,
but when people post them
on Thingaverse and they
use the brand name,
the brand sends us a DMCA
takedown, and we're complaint.
We comply.
And it'll be interesting.
So far on YouTube,
actually, you've
had a pretty interesting
ride with this.
I think, in fact, you're sort
of the test case for this
here, in that, there's
a whole procedure--
and I'm not a lawyer
--but there's a procedure
that once something comes
down, the person can say,
no, I really did make
that remake of "Sleepless
in Seattle."
And it looks exactly
like the original movie.
Put it back up.
And the only way it comes down
after that is from the courts.
Nobody's taken it
that far with things,
but it'll be an adventure.
And we're going to-- just like
we survived cassette tapes, VHS
machines, CD-R
drives --we're going
to explore it an make it work.
AUDIENCE: I want to hear
more about the guns part.
That was interesting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the guns.
BRE PETTIS: Oh, so the question
is what about 3D printed guns,
and I get this a lot.
And my standard answer
is basically like,
there's way more
interesting things
that you can make on
a MakerBot than a gun,
and way more easier ways
to acquire a firearm,
especially in this country.
You also have to
think, like-- yeah,
I think I would
just leave it there.
Yeah.
I think that's all to
really say about that,
because sure it's
super-exciting.
And there was a moment where
like every channel was like,
did you know that you might
have a 3D printer in your house,
and it could do
something very scary.
News at 11.
We had that kind
of hype around it,
which did a lot to promote
3D printing, frankly.
But it's just not our spirit.
At MakerBot we're obsessed with
unlocking people's creativity.
So I just-- it'll
be an adventure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRE PETTIS: Cheers.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
everyone for coming.
Thank you.
Let's give a warm
round of applause.